good morning everybody I have enormous
pleasure and honor in speaking to you
this morning as part of this important
conference in starting the morning
looking back at the history of culture
in crisis on the Korean Peninsula I feel
that we have millennia of time and no
time to consider and to think about I
have four topics which I hope to
interest you in in the short time
available to me I am fortunate to have
visited both Korea's in the course of my
work at the Victoria and Albert Museum
and in the British British Library and
I'm particularly interested to think of
Korea as a site for world culture for
cultural transmission and for lessons
for all of humanity about what happens
when conflict visits in unexpected ways
Korea as you see is surrounded by China
by Russia and by Japan we will return to
this in geopolitical environment in a
moment but I want to begin by looking at
an object which is not Korean an object
which is Chinese a famous lacquer
Blatter basket which was excavated in
the early 20th century when Korea was a
colony of Japan this basket has row upon
row of amazing 2,000 year old paintings
depicting people who honor their parents
honoring your parents is a human
characteristic it's a center point of
east asian Confucian civilization this
is the most potent memory of that long
tradition in Korea and in China it comes
to be in Korea because in the first
century AD parts of Korea had been
colonized by Han China
after the mid 20th century this object
is hardly known outside of Korea because
it is cut off by the accident of world
politics and it becomes part of the
collection of the North Korean National
Museum not the not the more open South
Korean national museum I'm fortunate to
have seen it myself I'm also concerned
to know where it might be now and I
think it's an object that just tells us
so much about how culture expresses
identity and culture crosses borders
that's my first Korean a lesson of
culture in crisis my second point from
Korea is about place religion and the
spread of faith from continent to
continent Korea is a site of wonderful
Buddhist temples many of which were
scattered across a beautiful senic area
the diamond mountains which spans the
eastern coast of the Korean Peninsula it
was much painted by the scholars of the
eighteenth and nineteenth centuries it's
still the subject of inspiration to
artists such as mr. Hwang in Jay who is
a eminent North Korean print artists
represented in our collection here sadly
during the korean war between 1950 and
1953 all the buddhist temples in the
Diamond Mountain area came to
destruction a huge heritage of human
civilization and belief was lost as a
protracted war and negotiation to and
negotiations about the fate of prisoners
of war dragged out across three years
carpet bombing continued across North
Korea until as one scholar has said
there was nothing left to bomb and at
that time all of the temples
we're lost here is sock one temple the
temple of the Buddha King as it was in
the Japanese period here it is in 1910
and here it is today one date one gate
we alone surviving other buildings are
nothing but architectural plans today
many temples in that eastern part of
Korea were lost in similar ways here is
a second temple senior temple all that
is left of what was once a large and
impressive agglomeration of buildings is
this one pagoda dating to the 6th
century AD it's easy to forget that such
destruct destruction accompanies almost
every conflict that we know of my third
point is about the accidents of history
that are visited upon unknowing
populations I'm turning now to the mid
19th century when Korea then known as
the Hermit Kingdom a resolutely closed
society which treasured its status as a
place apart with little contact outside
its own borders when that country came
into conflict with the forces of
expansionist colonial powers here we see
in the 1870s American marines attacking
con qua island which is near the court
the capital Seoul here we see battles on
the same island these skirmishes these
attacks on the Korean state went on for
decades in the 1880s we the British set
up a garrison in the island of komando
off the south of the Korean coast naming
it port Hamilton and setting up our own
station there we send warships we
we remain there for a couple of years
and then we moved on ready to engage in
other parts of East Asia this enforced
contact with the military might of the
Western world led to the militarization
of Korean people themselves we have
troops here being being trained and we
have the evidence of photography in
these 19th century periods to help us
trace the story we have all the
accoutrements of war as we've come to
know it hospitals refugees and we have
prisoners and border conflict moving
along my final reflections on conflict
and cultural heritage in Korea take us
to today and to the role of museums in
the presentation of cultural identity
the modern states of Korea are of course
to the Democratic People's Republic in
the north and the Republic in the south
each has a National Museum each has a
narrative each has a taxis value to
cultural heritage my message I hope is
one that sees some optimism for culture
over time as a unifying and
strengthening element in public life
both tangible cultural heritage of the
kind that we here in the museum world
are so concerned with and other cultural
heritage of a literary or performative
nature matter deeply to people all
around the world and that's the case in
both Korea's although this Stalinist
building of the centre of Pyongyang the
Korean Central history museum is a place
that is far in its museological practice
from the norms of the international
community it is nonetheless a portent
statement of the importance of culture
to the neck to the matter to the nation
and in the South 21st century
architecture technological achievement
and a much more open society have led to
a fine National Museum in the southern
part of soul which I imagine many in
this room will have will have visited
and we are able to see here the interior
of the National Museum in the south of
Korea in the Republic not forbidden to
photographers in the way that its
counterpart in the north is I wish the
conference success and look forward to
making many comparisons in the course of
the day thank you